وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية هي وسائل إعلام تجارية حرة تمامًا،
مملوكة بشكل ليبرالي تمامًا، لا يوجد ضغط من
الحكومة أو الأجهزة السرية أو الجيش أو
أشياء مثل هذا، أي شيء يفعله
يفعله طواعية، وقد قررت وسائل الإعلام الإسرائيلية
تقريبًا من الجدار إلى الجدار ربما باستثناء
صحيفتي حاريت، كل ما تبقى هو
ليس التلفزيون فقط، بل الصحف أيضًا، قرروا
أنهم جزء من
آلة الدعاية الإسرائيلية، وأنهم
صحفيون، وهذا ما يفعلونه بطريقتين،
الأولى هي الأكثر جدية،
فهم لا يظهرون غزة، فالمشاهد الإسرائيلي العادي
لا يرى غزة  على الإطلاق، يرى
الجنود، يرى عائلات
الرهائن، يُقال له ليلًا ونهارًا
عن التضحية الإسرائيلية،
يُقال له ليلًا ونهارًا، ما مدى شجاعة
الجنود الذين تراهم طوال أيام الأسبوع، 24
ساعة في اليوم، وشيء واحد فقط لا تفعله  لا
نرى معاناة غزة ووسائل الإعلام
قررت عدم إظهارها ليس لأن
أحداً دفع وسائل الإعلام إلى عدم القيام بذلك، فهم
يفعلون ذلك لأنهم يعرفون بوضوح تام
أن هذا ما لا يريد مشاهدوهم
رؤيته ويريدون إرضائهم
وبهذا يخونون مهمتنا الأولى وهي
رواية القصة كاملة